this is Cam Ranh Bay South Vietnam in
early nineteen sixty-five ships were
anchored in the harbor many for weeks
waiting to unload their precious cargo
of rations rifles and a munitions trucks
and tires plasma and a million other
items so vital to our forces in Vietnam
the reason for this great ship backlog
was a scarcity of unloading facilities
there was only one stone pier which had
been extended by army engineers to
accommodate two ships in addition there
was the transportation kors Lieutenant
Colonel John UD page the only beach
discharge vessel of its kind in the
United States Army inventory and other
amphibious means for the unloading of
cargo
you
the existing dot facilities were
scarcely sufficient to support the
tremendous logistical requirements of
our rapidly expanding forces measures
had to be quickly taken to increase the
volume of cargo discharge and reduce the
shipping backlog at the Anchorage's
additional peers would solve the problem
but it would take anywhere from 18 to 36
months plus the services of
approximately 400 workers to build one
permanent pier it was out of the
question it was too long to wait there
was however a temporary solution Adi
long prefabricated pier was in mothballs
in Charleston South Carolina this
particular peer built in 1952 for the
transportation Corps is 300 feet long 90
feet wide and 13 feet deep it is
equipped with 22 caissons and air Jack's
to elevate and hold it above water by
june nineteen sixty-five this completely
overhauled pier was ready for service it
left Charleston Harbor for Vietnam on 11
August
the D long pier was designed after World
War two by Colonel lb DeLong a former
army engineer during his service in the
Army Colonel DeLong saw the need for
peers which could be both mobile and
stable mobility to permit world wide
range and flexibility and stability to
make them in vulnerable to wind wave and
weather 12,000 miles and 81 days later
on 30 octobre 1965 the first II long
pier arrived in Cam Ranh Bay
installation began as soon as the pier
was positioned at the causeway provided
for it
the work of construction was conducted
by members of the 497 engineer company
as well as five civilian employees of
the DeLong corporation
the men worked against time in spite of
long hours and bad weather
they had but one concern to get the pier
finished as quickly as possible by
mid-december 1965 the pier was
operational
ships now had the capability to
discharge cargo at the rate of 800 tons
each per day all vital to our forces in
Vietnam
there were now two peers at Cam Ranh Bay
the old stone pier and the first deal on
pier which were capable of unloading for
ships simultaneously it was an
improvement yet not enough to completely
break the ship backlog at Anchorage not
only in Cam Ranh but in other waterways
of South Vietnam as well as a result on
a priority basis the army contracted
with the salon Corporation for
additional peers to expedite delivery
the DeLong corporation subcontracted the
work of construction to the Japanese
shipbuilding industry here the peers
were prefabricated within a period of 90
days
they are constructed to be towed into
position wherever and whenever they are
needed for doc pasilla T's either
permanent or temporary at the time these
scenes were photographed two sizes of
peers were being built the large or a
type barge is 300 feet long 80 feet wide
and 13 feet deep the smaller b-type
barge is 150 feet long 60 feet wide and
10 feet deep the caissons upon which the
barges rest are 140 feet long six feet
in diameter and are made of one and
one-half inch steel each case on ways 79
short tons it takes ten caissons to
support an a barge and from four to six
to support Abby barge the old type air
jack as seen here weighs 13 short tons
and can lift 160 short tons DeLong's new
improved air jack also being used in
Vietnam weighs 20 short tons and has a
lifting capacity of 500 short tons
immediately upon completion the barges
are towed to South Vietnam the trip
takes from two to three weeks depending
on the weather
this is camron to the first newly
constructed belong here in Vietnam 12
men can install a permanent pier in
about four weeks a temporary pier with
Jack's left on and caissons not capped
can be installed in about two weeks
alongside the pier to facilitate the
handling of the heavy caissons and Jax
is a work barge with the 150 ton crane
when the barge is in place the caissons
are laced into the well of the barge and
lowered until they rest on the bottom of
the bay next the air jacks are lowered
over the caissons and secured to the
deck with connecting tie bars when all
the caissons and air jacks have been
installed the barge is jacked up above
the water the action of the air jack can
be compared to a boy shinning up a pole
assume the pole to be a caisson of
uniform diameter and the jack the hands
and feet of the boy the jack has the
lower and upper sections connected by
air operated cylinders the positive
lifting connection is provided by the
tie rods secured between the upper
section and the load the two sections
ringing the case on carry grippers which
when inflated grip the caisson and when
deflated permit vertical movement
the lifting cycle is as follows grip for
load-bearing with the lower section with
upper section grippers released the
cylinders transfer their energy through
the tie rod to lift the load the upper
section grippers expand and secure the
load the lower section grippers release
while the retractor jack raises the
lower section to its new position this
cycle has raised the load 12 inches
the caissons are then driven into the
ocean bottom by a crane operated pile
hammer adapted to fit these large
caissons the barge can then be lifted by
the air operator Jack's to the desired
height
vendors to absorb the impact of docking
vessels are then bolted to each case on
and to the barge when all fenders have
been installed the pier is ready for
cargo operations as of january nineteen
sixty seven for Geelong peers are
operational in Cam Ranh Bay two in Queen
yawns and one each in Danang bung roll
vung tau and sada hip Thailand the total
United States discharge capacity for
Southeast Asia is 6,000 short tons of
cargo per day
you